we've talked about this before but you
have a production company that you've
formed with your pal
jason bateman that's right and the two
of you uh call it what do you call it
it's the the company's called dum-dum
yeah and uh because you guys used to
just call each other dum-dum that was a
nickname that we had for each it was a
mutual nickname okay
like uh you know like he would say
something like hey are we
we have more to do today i'm like no
dumb dumb we're done you know yeah
yeah yeah and it was just kind of fun
stuff sure um
yeah and uh so we decided we were trying
to come up with a name for this company
and we
so we use that and this company makes
ads you want to make ads
we make ad we we sort of make uh branded
content in the digital space as we say
um but it's basically ads thank you
um but yeah so we make ads we make ads
for companies you've made some real ads
for real companies you've been paid for
we made ads for orbit and we we did a a
talk show for denny's clap
go ahead um find i don't know why
and we're we're making like an original
series for this uh call of duty video
game so we do it for lots of different
brands
yeah four for you that's that's now you
said uh last time you were on the show
that you wanted to do an
ad no it wasn't you it was jason jason
said that he wanted i'll get you guys
messed up
um i'm just another actor you know uh
you guys said
i am burning with rage
you said or jason said whenever that um
that you killed yourself arnett um that
you wanted to make an
ad for this show yeah i said i think
that's a good idea
jason had mentioned that and so we
talked about it back at the headquarters
of dum dum
and uh we got together some of the
staffs everybody from the
from the 41st floor and above got
together yeah that's a big everyone in
the phone booth
it's a pretty big impression
it's quite it's quite an outfit we have
over there so uh we got together and we
said
we came up with like a pitch ad that we
wanted to run by you that we thought
we wanted you know that really
encapsulates the show and really
and sort of you made an ad you made a
sample ad we just did like a pitch ad
for you guys
we wanted to like focus on the strengths
of the show which we did not think were
necessarily you
so much you know we wanted to sort of
start it in a different spot we love you
we think you're a great brand we'll get
to you in a second
but we want to focus on some other stuff
first
let's let's take a look at this as an ad
you made through show it now it's just
something you put together yeah let's
show this
picture some of the guy i brought
brought a copy with me today
it's america's talk show formatted show
with action
music
[Music]
romance
and stars
[Music]
did we get the job that ad is gonna uh
never air um
up all night a terrific new show airs
wednesday nights at 8 on
nbc will you're a good man you're sure
let's put aside our differences